the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
and I have put on the second board just
a quick review of the key equations that
we use to do the direct method so
straight from Newton's second law the
first one second one the summation of
torques about some point a MIBG in which
case things get much simplified G being
a center of mass and if the point a is
moving then you have this extra term and
this is a new equation over here which I
got frustrated with this equation a few
days ago and derived something which I
think is more is easier to use so I'll
do a problem today using that expression
so I won't talk more about it now show
it to you in a minute and then finally
it's convenient at times to express
angular momentum with respect to a point
a as angular momentum about G Plus the
position vector from A to G times the
linear momentum so that's kind of the
material covered on the quiz and we're
going to use these equations I'm going
to today what I'm going to do is look at
a few problems from the point from the
point of view of both equations of
motion by the direct method and the
Lagrange's of talk about you know which
one's easier how do you you know when
should you choose this one want to
choose that one that's the sort of the
nature of today's lecture to sort of get
you prepped for the quiz and a little
bit more on generalized forces
you have questions about what's going to
be on the quiz balancing of rotors
there's a rotor anything that we spin
about an axis you know a rigid body
spinning about an axis you can call a
rotor of some kind and balancing is
usually on the axes are are fixed and so
is that this is this one this axis
passes through the center of mass so is
is this does this rotor is it statically
balanced right this rotor dynamically
balanced would you expect to when this
is spinning it's its direction of spin
is vertical right is the direction what
direction is is the direction of the
angular momentum of this object in the
same direction as angle of rotation no
and so that's and that's an indication
of dynamic imbalance angle momentum is
not in the same direction as the angular
rotation right all right and well we're
on that subject we'll just hit it
briefly here one other prop I need so
another rigid body and I don't know
where G is on this rigid body
so does this is rotating about an axis
is this object statically balanced just
from looking just doing this experiment
we're doing an experiment we're sticking
this on an axis and we're letting it do
its thing and I'm asking you is it
statically balanced how do you know so
it goes to a low point right and that
tells you what about the position of
this axis right the center mass has got
gravity puts a force at the centre of
mass creates a torque which brings it to
the low point right
does this object does this object have a
any symmetries that you could point out
or in other words could you in you
without doing any math tell me one
principal axis of this object
so you say I've got a dotted line around
here and that's a plane of what so
there's a plane of symmetry cutting this
thing through here so if you have if you
can identify one plane of symmetry then
where can you tell me that for sure you
know that you can make a principal axes
he says perpendicular to that plane any
place on that plane perpendicular to it
what do you think is it so now we've
identified it has a plane of symmetry
and that an ax is perpendicular to it an
axis of symmetry excuse me an axis a
principal axis should be perpendicular
to that plane but the question is where
do I put it where perpendicular to that
plane
can this axis be and be a principal axis
she says through G you agree with that
okay so certainly through G let's say
that that's really is G and I put it
through here and if it was exactly
through G it wouldn't rotate to a little
spot but it's pretty close it struggles
to get there that's definitely a
principal axis but are there more this
is kind of the point real point of the
question are there other allowable
principal axes in this direction and so
we haven't talked about this very much
any axis if this is a principal axis any
axis parallel to it's a principal axis
it's no longer through G it's no longer
statically balanced about that point but
it's still a principal axis in one one
way one measure of whether or not
something is a principal axis if you
know the principal axes of an object and
you write the mass moment of inertia
matrix of it with respect to G what does
that matrix look like or does it have
zeros and non zeros
two diagonal matrix if I'm so if I about
G is diagonal that means your computed
the moment mass moment properties with
respect to three principal axes if it's
diagonal and I those actually zahl
passed through G if I now take one of
those axes and say I want to move it
over here and you recomputed the inertia
matrix would it still be diagonal so
you've moved just one axis to another
spot parallel to its original one you
know this one is a principal axis I'm
going to move it just parallel only that
one axes the other two are staying where
they are just moved at parallel is that
also a principal axis or another way of
saying it does that mass matrix mass
moment of inertia matrix stay diagonal
to do any of the terms in it change
let's say this is the Z principal axis
and I move away so now you have the this
new mass moment of inertia matrix does
the i ZZ term change yeah by how much
and he says ml squared L being one here
and that's this thing known as parallel
axis there right if you move one axis
this thing is still any axis parallel to
one of those axes is also principal axis
so that's a subtle point we don't off
talked about it but any axis parallel to
principal axis is also a principal axis
okay great
let's think about a problem we've done
this problem before but now we have all
the full tools we have lagron we have
direct method so that's this problem of
the wheel on a horizontal plane kind of
a complicated distribution of mass for
which we know I Zizi about G is some
mass radius of gyration squared
maybe we measured it rather than
computed it so this thing is a slide nun
on ice and it has cord wrapped around it
I'm pulling with a force F call it f1
now I'll provide the inertial frame and
it's got some radius R and we'll say the
surface is frictionless
so I don't have a string wrapped around
but we're really talking about this
problem I'm pulling on the string and if
thinking slide and rotate so take a
second think about how many different
ways can you think of solving for the
equations of motion of this so this on a
quiz I want you to find the equations of
motion what method would you use and
what's this and then then you're
confronted with well I know more than
one method what's the simplest method
and before that you need to decide how
many coordinates you're going to need
how many equations are given so let's
start there how many independent
coordinates do you need to do this
problem so is so and well back up one
more question then is this a planar
motion problem so it's confined to one
plane I see a lot of heads nodding and
it rotates only with one degree of
freedom and rotation axis perpendicular
to the plane so this is a planar motion
problem so in general planar motion
problems have how many degrees of
freedom per rigid body so it sees a
bunch of threes okay does this one have
any constraints on those three degrees
of freedom so this has three degrees of
freedom you conceivably need three
equations of motion okay oh now so how
can what are the choices for getting
them what do you think about such a
minute you decide what way you would do
and then let's just kind of take a poll
in a minute you think about it and then
let's take a poll for how people would
do this problem
okay so what's your favorite well how
would you do it he'd use the direct
method about do you need a torque
equation about what point he'd use
senator math so he'd say direct method
and for the torque equation do it about
center mass anybody have a different way
they would do this problem is there
another way to do it
he wants to do the garage okay
everybody agree it could be done that
way all right so I agree and let's do
let's quickly see let's quickly do this
problem and so direct method I'm going
to make it easier on myself here so the
three coordinates you're going to need
an X Y and theta is what I've chosen for
the three coordinates to do this direct
method and to make it easy on myself I'm
going to align the force with my
coordinates so I'm going to make
essentially make theta zero so
that you're aligning f1 my force f1 with
the x-axis and if I do that then I can
say that some of the forces in the Y the
external forces in the Y Direction are
non-existent zero so that must be M y
double dot so y double dot is zero so we
know that's makes simplifies the problem
summation of the forces in the
x-direction external forces are f1 I and
they must equal to the mass times the
acceleration in the X direction and I'm
basically done for that equation well so
I'm doing this I'm saying this is my
inertial frame that an inertial frame
sure I'm just now I don't have now I can
get I don't have to break this force
into components f1 cosine theta in the
x-direction and f1 sine theta in the
y-direction and get to nan get a finite
amount nonzero amount for y double dot
nonzero amount or X double dot I end up
with three equations I have to work with
just by realigning it I can make this
problem even simpler so just to do it
quickly that's what I did and finally so
I've got two of the two of the three
equations done and finally the sum of
the torques about G
and we know the angular momentum of this
would be some ICC G times Omega Z would
be the angular momentum and it's deep D
by DT of that is easy about G Omega Z
dot which is state a double dot right
and what are the external torques so
figure it out what's the external torque
in this problem what is its size and
what's its direction
okay so give somebody give me a what's
the external torque with respect to
where to start with so we're summing
torques about G the center mass R cross
F right which comes out in what
direction K direction right and minus or
plus do your right hand rule and notice
I've drawn x and y such that positive z
is into the board pardon
so this is positive I did I put a
positive Z into the board on purpose so
that this would just work out our f1 in
the K direction and that's equal to AI z
Z theta whoops
I see Z about G theta double dot and
since the solid with respect to K you
can drop the unit vectors here and so we
have one equation we have two equations
and we have three equations and and
that's all we need to complete this is
three degrees of freedom to completely
define the motion yep you mean the my
double dot equals zero well let's let's
go let's in general you know that's what
I started this one when I didn't align
them then you're forced to use the three
right so the only difference between
what I did and this probe making a
problem slightly more messy is that if I
had let theta this angle be other than
zero I would have had to have come up
with three nonzero acceleration
equations right so I'd say technically
or I just say I think it's prudent if
you're ever not sure if you can look at
it and by inspection write down my
double dot is zero you've essentially
just written an equation of motion
rather than say let's
ignore it I keep it in here I just put
it on the paper my double dot equals
zero and that's your first trivial
equation of motion that it is an
equation of motion because this body has
a true degree of freedom in that
direction that's really the point
don't confuse trivial results because
there's no external forces with
constraints
it's unconstrained in the X direction
there in the Y direction the way I've
set it up so I think you're safer if you
just if you if it's is just to say the
torques or the forces in that direction
or zero and we write it down okay let's
look at this problem from the point of
view of lagron it's also equally simple
by Lagrangian relized forces actually
Garage is harder because you have to
think your way through the generalized
forces in this problem and I got myself
in a pickle with this problem I spent
hours trying to figure out a good
explanation of a conundrum I ran into
with the generalized forces
so let's look I'll tell you what that
was in a second let's look at the garage
so you need T and we're pretty good at
this now i with respect to g ZZ theta
dot squared that's your rotational
kinetic energy one-half M X dot squared
plus y dot squared the translational
translational kinetic energy associated
with the center of mass notice this is
what's back to the center of mass
how about V
potential energy in this problem any
doll zeros right now there's no Springs
there's no gravity in this group in this
plane operating in this plane so this is
zero let's make this problem is going to
be particularly simple so
so in the theta direction here this
derivative with respect to Q dot gives
us isay theta dot and the time
derivative that is easy they to double
dot T with respect to theta
nothing V with respect to theta nothing
and on the right hand side we need to
get Q theta here and the other equation
the we it's the X equation
well actually we could have X&Y okay so
what about the X equation derivative
with respect to X dot I get an MX dot
time derivative MX double dot and with
respect to Y the thing about lagron
jhula grunge just do do write down the
total expression and just crank it out
because if you say oh well I know this
is trivial then you're actually
employing some information from the
direct method if you're saying I know
that some of the forces in this
direction is zero so when you're
straight forward straight out the fine
LeGrande you can do it without any
reference at all to newton right so in
this case we just blindly clunk along
and we say well what's the derivative
now with respect to y dot well I get an
M Y dot time derivative y double dot
this derivative would be zero this
derivative is zero and over here I get Q
Y now I'm left so the left hand side of
lagrangians remember you just add these
terms together
and those these are going to be our
three equations of motion that result
and now the remaining work is to get
these three generalized forces so let's
go back to our picture if we had lined
it up like this and now we give it a
general a little virtual displacement
Delta Y how much work it's done done and
so you read so you just suddenly realize
that oh I went to a lot of work for
nothing here this equation is trivial
nothing happens there and so now it's
reduced to doing the Q X and Q Y so just
to give us some practice
let's try to let's do Q theta and QX the
rigorous kinematic way
I'm going to draw the general picture
here because this is where I got myself
into trouble you know you're working
along with the problem then something
doesn't quite work for you
well I'd set this problem up to do
generalized to compute the generalized
forces and I set it up looking like set
it up like this so that theta is 0 it's
lined up like that and I started
thinking about then generalized my
little virtual displacements and I got
into a conceptual problem that I
couldn't sort out for a while and I'll
I'll work it into the explanation here
so I'm going to set this up more
generally I have an angle theta here and
this is my f1 so to do this by this
kinematic way I need to find a position
vector here's a point I'm going to call
it D and this is my point G and here's O
so I have a position vector going to
here so our G and a position vector
going to here that's our of D with
respect to G and a position vector from
here and that's our D and O and our B in
O is our G and L plus R D with respect
to G I can write that they're vectors ok
so I'm going to need those and so what
is our G and oh well I have this
coordinate system it's going to be some
X I plus y J in the inertial frame and
then our D with respect to G I need to
have a some kind of coordinate system
that rotates with the body so I'll call
this y1
and this x1 that's rotating with the
body so now this one down here is - are
in the j1 direction so that's the
position of this point D with respect to
O written as a sum of two vectors
and I'm eventually going to need to be
able to express this j1 in an inertial
frame so here's this little vector J 1
and I need its components in the J and I
directions so it's made up of a piece
like that piece like this and this angle
here is Theta so little J 1 so I can
convert I can move from this unit vector
system to that one by this
transformation I'm going to need that in
a minute
invoke it right now so my position
vector here is the X component is X
can't read my plus I crossed out a plus
and a minus I got to sort this out
carefully here
is this right
what do you think what have I done wrong
so this is the plus I direction this
piece here is so minus sine theta in the
I plus cosine theta in the J are the
components I'm missing a minus sign
there okay so I want to collect the I
pieces together so I have an X in the I
and I have a minus R minus sine theta so
plus R sine theta this is the icon
contribution and then over here I have a
Y and a minus R cosine theta in the J
then I have the this vector all worked
out in my core in my inertial frame so
now I can say that remember Q J dot d R
is through a virtual deflection with for
the jafe contribution so in this case
I'm interested in say the one in the
ones we do first the X direction so this
is f one in the i dot derivative of our
D with respect to X Delta X but now I
haven't I can work this out I can figure
this one out directly now because I have
an expression for R that vector in terms
of one set of unit vectors and I can
take the derivative with respect to X
and the only X that shows up in here is
this so the derivatives pretty simple
just one so this is f1 I dot I Delta X
so this tells us that Q x equals f1 no
great surprise we know the answer to
that before and I oh I made a mistake
what didn't I I was mixing the two you
know I did a simplification when I did
the direct one is f1 in the I direction
so f1 has components vector f1 has
magnitude f1 times cosine theta I plus
sine theta J and so down here I need to
put those in and take the dot product so
the only dot product that will matter is
the I component this is going to be f1
cosine theta I dot this which we know
this gives us just an I so I'm leaving
out the J piece so I end up here with f1
cosine saving does that look right so
here's your theta
here's your this is coast f1 cosine
theta so if for a coordinate system
that's squared up like this it's only
that term is in the f1 direction and
this this would come out correctly now
and if we let if we now a reorient our
coordinate system so that theta is 0
then the this then this would just turn
out to be f1 if you can see that this is
f1 cosine theta without
on through all the work what's qy for
this system
sure
f1 sine-theta we won't go through all
the work but you go through the same
taking the derivatives in this case the
derivative of R with respect to Y and
then dot it with F and you get f1 sine
theta in the J direction
so there's qy now the problem I ran into
conceptually is around this other piece
so q theta the virtual work done in the
theta direction we know has to do with
rotation and that is going to be some f1
dot now this is the derivative of our D
with respect to theta Delta Theta so our
D is here and it's indeed a function of
theta right and so I can take a
derivative of the respect to theta and
I'll get derivative of that our sine
theta term and I get a derivative of the
R cosine theta term but here's how I got
myself in trouble it took me and this is
the sort of thing that happens to all of
us at work in a problem
throw in a simplification and then
something doesn't work well well if you
had oriented the axis initially so that
the force is aligned with X and
perpendicular to Y then this theta angle
is zero right and you don't when you set
it up you don't end up with the the
cosine of 0 is 1 and sine of 0 is 0 you
don't end up with the cosine and sines
in there to take derivatives of you just
jump to the simplification you just find
out that you just have are in the in the
J there's no R and though there's no R
sine theta term it's just vanished on
you and just and now you need to take
the derivative to do this step
you know educate with it as huh what
have I done wrong well you need to leave
in order to do this method you need to
leave it in the sort of general
formulation and then that they to be 0
at the end if you want to do that so if
I had if I had then it finished it I can
do this for this general problem and
then let theta go to 0 and the answer
will come out all right so should we do
this so this is f1 dot this so f1 dotted
with the derivative of R with respect to
theta so I get an R cosine theta in the
eye and the derivative of this term root
of cosine theta is minus sine theta
times at minus is a plus R sine theta in
the J Delta Theta and I do this dot
product so I get the I times the eyes
and the J terms time the J terms
and it all works out nicely sine squared
plus cosine squared you get one and you
find out the torque isn't care about the
angle does that make sense absolutely I
did this on purpose to give us a little
more practice using this kinematic
grind-it-out method but but for sure the
intuitive method would have yielded
results a lot faster here right we would
said let's have a little deflection
Delta X what's the virtual work done
well would have been F 1 cosine theta
Delta X it would be Q X Delta Theta
Delta X Q Y Delta Y would be F 1 Delta Y
sine theta and we're done
and the rotation 1 we would have looked
at this and said how much in a little
motion Delta Theta how much does this
move it moves R Delta Theta times
crossed with the F that it moves through
or dot product with that distance would
have given you F 1 R Delta Theta equals
Q theta Delta Theta so what we could
have done it in you know a minute and
sometimes it kind of doing it the hard
rigors would get you in trouble I didn't
have the sine of this I the cosine
Thetas and sine theta is working out in
this and I couldn't take the derivative
netiquette what did I do and I finally
realized it made the problem too simple
simplified it too soon okay so I wanted
to use this as a stepping stone to
something I meant to cover perhaps weeks
ago there's a general little lesson that
we can learn from this which you've
probably been taught before but I'm
going to remind you here's a rigid body
got some center of mass and I've got a
force
acting on it here just some arbitrary
position and angle so that force has a
line of action and it's perpendicular
that line of action is a distance which
I'll call D here and we know that an R
cross F we can this force exerts a
moment about G that would be R cross F
where R goes from here to here but it
that it's only the component
perpendicular to it so we know that this
is going to create a moment but I'm
gonna draw pictures yet here for a
moment this diagram is the same as I
could draw the same peanut here same as
the following a force here that's F and
another force at G that's F equal and
opposite so it's like adding 0 to the
problem so I can do that with with
impunity and I still have my force F
down here so this problem is equal to
that problem so but now this force and
this force equal and opposite cancel one
another but create what's called a
couple a moment that we can compute
about my point G here so these two
forces create just a pure torque leaving
this as a force they're equal opposite
so no net force but they create a torque
in this direction and there's a
remaining force on the center of mass so
this whole thing is also then equal to
the equivalent of a torque around the
center of mass and a force applied at
the center of mass
and in this case the torque would be DF
this problem is Z this problem is easier
to do if you're trying to compute
generalized forces than the one we
started with because now the position
vector that we need goes only to the
center of mass okay so and the general
rule for this you have a body you have
several forces F 1 F 2 F 3
that's equal to the body with G with a
total F total on it and a moment a
torque total and F total the vector is a
summation of the FI s and T the torque
total is the summation of each of these
guys here's G this has R 1 here's an R 2
here's an R I to the 8th force so this
is a summation of the are I cross F eyes
so if you sum all the forces and compute
the equivalent torque about the center
of mass some all the forces and apply it
at the center of mass then this problem
is equal to that problem so these can
come in handy when you're trying to
simplify problems
and for this particular problem
let's draw our hockey pack going to put
my force in the simplest direction here
but there's my force this problem is
equal doing the same thing here the same
thing as if I had drew forces like this
and that gives me a quiver I have this
couple here produces a torque and
there's a net force acting on the center
of mass so this problem is equal to this
problem now torque and a force both
acting at the center of mass and the
torque is our F 1 in the K and the force
is just F 1 in the positive direction
okay and our but now what is the little
R vector we're going to do this the
kinematic way from here to G this is R 1
I'll call it and that's it I only now I
have everything acting here and Q X
Delta X is F 1 dot derivative of R with
respect to X Delta X but R is what is R
it's X I + YJ a derivative of R 1 with
respect to X is just 1 and derivative of
R in the I and derivative of our of
respect to Y is just J so this becomes a
trivial calculation f 1 i dot I I get Q
X equals F 1 Delta X and I get Qi Qi is
F 1 which is in the I Direction dot J is
0 and I get Q theta ah Q theta now do I
use this expression so I'm not dealing
with little changes in distance anymore
when you can put rotation when you put
moments about centers of mass it's just
easier this one you call it intuitive
but this is just going to be some delta
theta is equal to the torque total
torques acting at the center of mass dot
delta theta and in this case the torque
is in the K direction Delta Theta is in
the K direction and this is our F 1 K
dot K Delta Theta which just gives us
our F 1 equals Q theta so the torque
equations you can write up straight out
you don't have to take derivatives
anything to do with change in position
it's just a little rotation Delta Theta
so it simplifies this problem and
actually totally avoids the conundrum I
got into I work everything about the
center of mass of that rigid body the R
gets easier the derivatives get easier
and the torque becomes obvious how it
applies
okay
let's talk about I have a pendulum but
kind of a weird shape
but the pendulum has the following
property so at weird shape that may be
of this it's got one plane of symmetry
like this does and I'm going to put what
I do with my axle I'm going to put the
axis of rotation perpendicular to that
plane of symmetry somewhere not at G not
at the center of mass so just what I've
done here I can make to any object it
has a plane of symmetry five have it
rotate about an axis that's
perpendicular to that plane of symmetry
it becomes a simple pendulum and you can
write down but would by inspection what
the and attempts at what the equation of
motion is so how many degrees of freedom
does this system have so is it first of
all in is it planar motion okay so it
has it most three and how many and it
has a pin through it that doesn't allow
it to move in X or Y how many
constraints is that - so how many when
you got left one so this is a single
degree freedom problem and I've chosen
to have it move about an axis that is is
this axis a principal axis of this body
absolutely okay and so if I asked you
what's the mass moment of inertia of
this if I gave you eyes easy about G for
this thing and this distance what would
you tell me that mass moment of inertia
about the pivot is
now give me give you this what's the
rest of it not at G got some distance
here if you're given L will call it okay
so parallel axis remember ml squared so
we know that that's true so what's the
and the G is over here someplace and
this is this distance L and what's the
equation of motion for this and it's
it's a gravity axe no damping for now
what's the equation of motion right off
the top of your head you've done enough
of these I'll give you one minute think
about it we'll figure out the equation
of motion for this problem
I highly recommend you don't do the
garage okay
okay somebody give me their equation of
motion
so what method do you use would you
choose to use simplest one you can think
of direct about what point about a and
what do you say what's the what what
equation do you apply general equation
yeah that would be the nth that would be
part of the answer in the equation
remember I wrote the list of one two
three over there which one do you use
just the second one right and the
nuisance terms go away
point a is not moving so sum of the
torques is equal to DHD T and it's H
with respect to a right so so that's H
right d by dt y z z with respect to a
theta double dot k equals the sum of the
external torques and the rest of the
problem is finding the external torques
what's the Freebody diagram look like so
here's the object possibly a are X and
an R Y and an M G those are your process
they will set you free body diagram
right so here's the mg down what's the
torque that that mass that that
gravitational force puts on this object
with respect to point a R cross F right
R cross F into the board is that
positive or negative and what's the
length of this R well from here to here
is I guess so that's is L so the length
of this side of that triangle L sine
theta L sine theta cross mg and it is
positive or negative what we decide
looks like it's this is positive theta
XY system and it's negative minus M G L
sine theta or done so generically and
this is also in the K direction so we
can drop the case now we have our
equation of motion isay theta double dot
plus MGL sine theta
any single degree of freedom pendulum
made out of a body rigid body and
rotating about an axis that is a
principal axis as that equation of
motion any of them no matter what the
shape of you can rotate it about a
principal axis that and not through G is
if you put what's the natural frequency
if you run the axis through G what's the
torque zero nothing happens right just
doesn't want to do anything but as soon
as it's not through G anything oscillate
that's because of the UK this is now a
differential equation I need to say zero
here there's no other forces we've had
damping force then it would show up but
this is a generic undamped equation of
motion for any single degree of freedom
pendulum rotating about an act what one
of its principal axes and if the body
you're shown or given has a single plane
of symmetry then you can figure out one
way immediately that you know this will
that equation applies any axis
perpendicular to that plane of symmetry
is a pendulum base that equation and the
I with respect to a you can get from
simple parallel axis if you're told what
i with respect to G is okay questions
I'm going to put up two additional
problems and I'm not going to solve them
we're going to talk about them you're
going to tell me how you would go about
doing I mean they wouldn't be bad
problems for you to practice on
and you've actually seen both of them
before so the first one pulley rotating
about that fixed axis and this is that
thing we called Atwoods machine how to
draw my coordinates so I have my i ZZ
about g some m 3 kappa squared that's
given the radius of gyration of this
pulley so that's his mass moment of
inertia about the center and you know
are you could specify a theta and we
have a pair masses start off like this
m1 m2 and this now so there's not going
to say no slip this rope goes over the
pulley no slip initially stationary I
let go I want to have I want an equation
of motion for this system so how many is
it first of all is it a planar motion
problem ok how many rigid bodies how
many potential e degrees of freedom 9 ok
how many do you think there really are
going to end up with here how many how
many how many do you expect to find how
many necessary degrees of coordinates
you're going to need to completely
describe the motion I see someone's
going up everybody believed that lots of
constraints we got we're not going to
let this we're constraining this to move
and only allowed it to move up and down
these can't rotate
so there's one for each these can't go
in the this direction so two more this
can only rotate no translations so you
end up you you end up with one and
finally there's this no flip condition
which means that our theta equals x
that's one final one that you need to
write there okay so if you had that
gotten this far find the equation of
motion what method would you use so your
choices are here and direct method
l'orange think about it how would you
what's the easiest way for you to do
this problem maybe an ancillary question
is how many ways can you think of that
you could do this problem I mean
different approaches could you use
so how many ways can you how many ways
can you think of doing this problem
Kristen I just picking out her budget
give me the answer any way you want to
do it by the garage how else could you
do it if you if you did it by LeGrande
got the answer and said I want to check
it what would you do next right but how
where where would you apply would you
use torques would you use forces how
would you get go about doing this we did
that I mean I work that I actually did
this problem by that method earlier in
the term torques about a the pivot works
fine actually it's pretty pretty
efficient okay so LeGrande
torques about a only there's one degree
of freedom right how many equations you
need to write to do this problem just
one so the sum of the torques about a
will give you the answer look Ron's
equation will give you the answer okay
that's a good good problem to go
practice to practice on another problem
this is not very big it's basically this
problem is it just you've seen this I'm
sure you've been shown this in physics
and stuff before there's the falling
stick problem I can't you can't set this
up without having some friction so
there's definitely friction on the table
but until it hits it's doing some things
and so there's two problems that you
could set up and try to do one this is a
problem with four no friction
frictionless table and then you could
allow friction okay
tricky thing about allowing friction is
do you think there's a normal force
so let's say our usual friction model is
the friction force is mu times the
normal force is the normal force change
with time
in this problem so standing up what's
the normal force mg right but and the
sum of the forces in the vertical
Direction is mass times the acceleration
in the vertical direction and what are
the if you draw a Freebody diagram of
this problem so let's draw it now here's
my Beth if there's no friction force oh
I still without friction force I still
have a normal force and I still have mg
pulling down here so the sum of the
forces in the Y certainly have a minus
mg plus N equals the mass times the
acceleration in the Y direction and if
you solve for n
do you then the issue if my question is
this remain constant depends on whether
or not a why remains constant right do
you think the acceleration in the Y
direction of this thing will change as
it goes more and more horizontal so
here's some nod up and downs and left
and right I think it's going to change
for sure you can't assume that it won't
change so you have to assume that it
will change and that means in this
normal force becomes to a function of
time which makes this problem makes
certain ways of doing this problem a
little harder so how many ways to see
the friction let's do a no friction B
with friction okay no friction first of
all is it a planar motion problem yep
okay we can we can do that so at most
three degrees of freedom how many does
this one have work this one out figure
out how many degrees of freedom this
problem has how many separate equations
you need to come up with
so you decide what you're let's say
we're going to use Lagrange
what would your generalize coordinates
be to do this problem
it's a problem a no friction how many
generalized coordinates how many degrees
of freedom how many generalized
coordinates do you need I heard a three
I hear one somebody give me two I got a
- all right it's good obviously a good
question so at most there can be three
because we've agreed that it's planar
motion does this problem have any
constraints where so it can't move in
the Y direction okay so if any part of a
body can't move in in in translate then
there's no translation in that direction
in a pure translation of the body in
that direction so there's a constraint
in the in the Y if we draw a coordinate
system here constraint the Y's true so
we're down to two are there any other
constraints no no it's not leaning
against a wall this is just a stick this
is this this is the problem so it's
definitely can't move through the table
so it's constrained in Y we've got that
so now that leaves us at most - are
there any other constraints
how many say no how many say yes if you
say yes you got to tell me what it is
but I don't see any others so we're left
with two we need two coordinates which
what might we pick here what would you
pick you're now confronted with this
problem do you have rotational can if
you're going to use a garage you have a
rotational kinetic energy in this
problem you're probably going to need an
angular mo
what else would you need so we're going
to need an angle for sure say again
you're going to need the height of the
center of mass yeah you're going to need
a potential energy expression but we've
decided that Y is constrained hmm
so if you can't have a theta and a Y
let's make this our theta what else is
there X you're going to need an X so
let's our generalized coordinates are
going to be say an X and a theta and but
you do need to be able to write down the
potential energy expression and it
involves motion in the Y so what do you
do right so what's the height of this
thing is above the ground if some L over
2 cosine theta equals y something like
that right I might have a depending on
whether you make I haven't thought this
through
whether or not it's X Y this way or X Y
that white data might be plus or minus
this could be there might be a much sign
in there but basically this is the theta
and Y are are constrained you know one
you know the other so you do your
potential energy expression this way
okay now so now you're in front now
you've we've gotten that far we know we
need to two coordinates we're going to
use X and theta but now you have to
decide what method to use direct method
using one of these or Lagrange what
would you do
how would you go about to quiz you've
got 20 minutes to finish and you want to
do this in the safest quickest possible
way
what would you try you know this is you
know when this is you know the realistic
situation right next Tuesday what do you
most
what do you trust yourself to do for the
most it's probably what you ought to do
in a quiz situation
and how many ways can you think of doing
this how many ways could you do this
problem to anyway
direct and direct where would you use
where would you choose to you're going
to need a torque equation to do this
problem if you use direct where would
you take your torques about think about
that where for this problem you're using
on direct method where you're going to
compute the torques about what point so
you can do it about that point you could
call this point a here yep and what a
question would you get you now you've
got to use that equation that's got the
problematic terms in it right and what
it's alright you can cut you and punch
those through and do it that will work
and if you use Lagrange you've got to be
able to figure out the potential and
kinetic energies and so forth okay
so we could all of you do this by
L'Orange I mean this is a good one to go
practice on it's not that hard do it
it's a good practice problem now add
friction to the B problem it now has
friction can you I don't think these
LeGrande you good choice if it now has
friction okay and I think it's got a
problem and I'd be careful using
Lagrange if ahead friction not that
Lagrange's perfectly just not if it is
certainly valid it's just hard why is it
hard
yeah well yeah might be hard to find
what do you need to know to so are there
any external non-conservative forces in
the problem with friction friction okay
you're going to have to figure out the
friction force and to figure out the
friction force you're going to have to
apply direct method in no other way you
are going to have to apply some direct
method to do this problem no matter what
so you can't you can't just say either
but you can't the garage is not going to
just bail you out and not have to solve
some of the F equals MA
and torque and those sort of things to
figure out what friction is so there are
problems that Lagrange's it is isn't all
as simple as we sometimes make it out to
be
all right I've run a couple of minutes
over thank you we'll see you in class on
to see we'll do some more review